[Music]
christina is in ocala florida hi
christina welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and ken thank you for taking my
call this is a wonderful birthday
present
oh happy birthday
thank you it's the big 4-0 it's kind of
scary oh
oh i don't know how you're going to make
it old woman
i know that's what my husband said poor
me
um i have a question because my husband
and i have been working our baby steps
which is wonderful and
we're kind of concerned on how to deal
with his father
we want to handle it in a way that his
retirement is going to be a blessing
instead of a new curse for us
um let me give you a little background
he is a single man and has been
since him and his mom divorced 40 years
ago
he spent the last 20 years
renting he's never bought or owned a
home
he at one point leased and owned three
cars a boat jet ski and two motorcycles
he's always had more than one car and
he's one person
um
he's retired now all he has a social
security a little bit of pension and a
hundred thousand dollars to his name and
he thinks buying a gun is an investment
and we're just terrified that
we need to fit him into our baby steps
because we're gonna end up having to
take care of him if we can't get him to
stop wasting money
okay um
what do you guys make a year
uh a 130 000 i i work four jobs and run
a business trying to clean up our own
mess
and
we have our own goals and dreams and i
just feel like one out of guilt we're
all he has i mean my husband is his only
son
um
you know there's nobody else that's
gonna take him in it would have to be us
so
i feel like if we could get him on the
right path he might be okay but that's
having to explain to him that you know
what you're gonna have to stop blowing
money
and maybe work a part-time job because
he thinks he can buy a house but that's
going to take all his money if that's
even enough
a hundred thousand dollars always by
much how old is he
68
houses health
uh well he just had surgery for prostate
cancer but that all went well so
we're hoping the health maintains but
that's my other concern your husband has
a good relationship with his dad
oh yeah we've always been close with him
and we have a good relationship and a
couple of years ago we sat down and
talked to him about all this and kind of
tried to explain to him
making eight percent he's got some
finance guide his credit union telling
him making eight percent and whatever he
has been that he doesn't understand is
good we're like no
that's not good and he thinks it is and
he doesn't understand half of what
they're doing they just he gives them
his money and they do whatever and he
thinks it's good
and after that many years of them doing
whatever all you have is a hundred
thousand dollars to show for it i think
you need a new guy
i think you're more upset about this
than anybody else on the planet
oh
it terrifies me yeah i don't think
you're i don't think your husband's
upset about it and i don't think his
dad's upset about it
well my husband's worried because he
doesn't not as worried as you the other
day
well
i'm nervous to talk to you too but my
husband's like i need to talk to him but
you know how do i talk to him without
you know hurting his feelings or being
kind of a jerk about it because like
he's rented a house for 30 years paying
250 a month no i can just tell you you
don't need to talk to him
because your state of mind is not a
state of mind that he's gonna listen to
you
well no i won't talk to him my husband
has to yeah your husband has to that's
not my problem i know i know but it's um
you're you're
because you're you're um
you have a lot of anxiety about this and
it's going to come through
and it's going to sound bossy to him and
you don't want that it won't be it won't
be uh profitable for the conversation
your husband can sit down and talk to
him but i'll give you a prediction your
husband can sit down and talk to him and
probably nothing's going to change
okay because i don't think the old man
wants to change
i don't think he gives a rib
right
and so he's 68 years old he's 68 years
old he has a hundred thousand dollars he
buys guns
um and he pays his rent in cars
well he just now found out he has to
move out of that so now he just went and
dumped money to rent a trailer until he
can figure out where he wants to live
okay
on top of his two cars one of the most
one of the most painful things that we
all go through as adults is watching
people we care about be stupid
[Laughter]
because you can't make them not be
stupid
everyone has people in their family and
in their friend group that are doing
things that we all look at them and go
um
and you you know the the only hope is is
that occasionally you can knock a knot
on one of them's head and get their
attention and turn them around
but i don't hear anything in this story
that makes me think he's going to listen
to your husband do you really think
there's any scenario where your husband
says can you i don't have any magic
words for your husband to use
and i just don't think this old man
really cares about i think he's got his
own way of doing things and i don't
think he uh cares so here's the thing
you make 130 000 a year you can probably
buy him a little bit of groceries if
he's completely starving to death
you might even help him with his rent a
little bit here or there
a few times
even though he's been a complete twerp
with money and doesn't really deserve
with his irresponsibility to help but
you can afford to dump a little bit of
money in that and you're it's not gonna
make you broke
you're not gonna give this guy a hundred
grand yeah
nor do you have to pay off his debt no
all those boats and cars you can sell
all that if something happens to him
yeah you're not responsible for any of
that yeah all we want to do is just make
sure he's not hungry and homeless yeah
well yeah that was kind of our point
it doesn't take a lot of money
i mean it doesn't take a lot of money if
if you're paying his rent you decide
where he lives
or he doesn't have to live there i mean
i'm gonna get old cheap a little cheap
uh trailer or a little one-bedroom
apartment or something let him rent
and you can do that depending on where
he is a few hundred here are there right
and uh the same thing with groceries so
and you guys can afford to do that and
by the time you have to do it which will
be many years from now if you ever even
do have to do it your wealth is going to
be on track because you're doing smart
stuff
but it's just it's just i agree with the
pain in your voice and the desperation
in your voice because it's just hard
to watch people you care
be self-destructive
yeah i mean well yeah when we feel like
he we're it but we have to
do no you don't you don't yeah you don't
have to
you don't have to do anything
there's not a law
that says
you've done cocaine your whole life and
now i'm supposed to pay for your rent
there's no i mean you've misbehaved
whatever form of misbehavior you want to
come up with your whole freaking 70
years on the planet
and you're and now i'm obligated to feed
you
not really but i probably will just
because i'm a compassionate person
he's not going to take you guys down you
either have so much fear and i get it
there's so much unknown and you're in
the middle of the struggle and you guys
are busting your gazelle intense and
you're working four jobs and you're
going going going going but listen he's
not going to drag you down he's not
going to drag you guys down so that fear
needs to go away but he's it's
disgusting sure of course because you're
working so hard and he's not doing squat
yeah
you know you're being so responsible and
he's so irresponsible i get that it's
disgusting to me to hear about him and i
don't even know him
you know i get it i i understand but
he's what is he he's most of america
right yeah and so he's irresponsible and
slovenly and
out of control and you know and and then
acts like somebody did something to him
and nobody did anything to this old guy
he just farted around all his money till
it was gone
right
yeah yeah so i i think you can calm
and and just lovingly i mean
please don't talk to him let your
husband
and his son and just say dad i'm gonna
knock a nod on your noggin if you don't
quit this
because i'm afraid i'm gonna have to
feed your butt because you're
misbehaving now you need to be grown up
and this is how he needs to talk to him
because this whole guy doesn't do
subtlety does he
and that's that's what your son's gonna
have to do but that's the only shot he's
got getting through to him and it's just
lovingly dad i love you but you're being
a butt
and you gotta stop it
and you're just going to have to have
this conversation and then see how it
goes
hallmark needs to make one of those
cards right there the dave ramsey dad i
love you but you're being a butt
that's that'll be a big
channel